la charte des affamés ce n'est pas parce
que je suis jeune qu'il est normal
d'accepter un stage en dessous des
compétences devaient payer moins de 8
euros de l'heure comme l'euro et de
travail et 75 eur par tonne d'être
traités comme de la merde on va dire
d'être méprisés si certains méprisés
comme de la merde ça revient au même
moi c'est zoé j'ai 21 ans j'ai arrêté
les études chercheurs n'apporte chercher
là bas je vous présente jouer je vous ai
parlé en 6,7 colloque c'était comme une
famille et qui dit famille des
embrouilles c'est quoi c'est parce que
je baise bas c'est quoi ton délire
est-ce que je baise mal non tu bosse
bien et bien sûr tout ce buzz d'or lycée
arthur ça faisait cinq ans qu'il
travaillait dans une banque
moi je serais vous je voudrais pas un
petit chien jamais dow jones la nuit il
réussissait à y trouver son compte
on se presse marc guez pour caroline
quant à elle son emploi du moment ne lui
permettait pas vraiment de mettre ses
compétences à profit qu'ils ont une
capacité de concentration proche du
chaton pas moi aujourd'hui je me bouge
je trouve un taf
raymond cacolac c'est à ce moment là que
j'ai compris des jeunes c'est pas juste
une catégorie d'âge fait une place
sociale
on nous devons tous font rien nous
donner en échange pour qu'ils mentent
pour récurer des chiottes pour faire des
fichiers excel jusqu'à pas d'heure comme
éric liaud non faut qu'on entre en gare
on va créer une liste des choses qu'on
n'acceptera plus one short exactement
notre objectif attaquer le système de
l'intérieur pour la première fois j'ai
compris qu'elle force nous pouvions être
tout ce qui nous manque c'est la
sensation pour nous attend si on veut
changer les choses il faut penser plus
grand mais il faut surtout penser
ensemble
un seul titre dans l'actualité de les
jeunes ont disparu c'est pas possible ça
veut pas s'arrêter à l'hymne la
stagiaire bordel